first of all thank you guys for making a
time uh to be on uh with us I know the
audience has been anticipating this for
a while
uh uh obviously uh when we had that sit
down together we were together for three
days I think nearly 30 hours of footage
which has now come to a completion of 10
episodes uh of which there's behind the
scenes there's a lot of different things
that the audience will be seeing but you
know I kind of want to ask you guys a
couple open-ended questions how are you
doing right now with in regards to this
project being launched how are you guys
doing to yourself maybe Michael if you
can uh tell us uh on your rent of uh
your level of enthusiasm with this Mafia
States of America project
I'm doing great Patrick I just want to
get it underway a lot of people are
asking about it uh you know a lot of
different comments and uh it's time we
get it out there you know I'm I'm very
enthused to see it happen
Sammy how about yourself
I guess yes uh
um
I'm waiting for it to come out I've been
waiting a while
it's a little awkward time right now but
I'm waiting for it to come out as well
well I remember when we had you on the
podcast you made it very clear when I
said it may come out this year it may
come out next year you had a very
strategic way of making sure it came out
this year which is uh uh coming out in
2021 instead of next year and we're
pretty excited about launching it but
Michael uh Sammy for yourself the market
you know it seems so many people are
anticipating this conversation between
the two of you uh specifically since we
had so many different discussions from
the life on your end uh what where are
you at right now yourselves uh no one at
this phase of the season when this is
being launched meeting has there been
any conversations between the two of you
about this project yourself so Sammy
what are you thinking right now what's
on your mind
well we did have conversations about it
and I thought we were on the same page
as far as trying to put this back
together and solving our problems I'm
not sure if this did solve our problems
uh Michael put out a video just not too
low and I didn't like this [ __ ] video
and I think we had some words so uh but
we still did this I don't want to
interfere with the project I don't want
to destroy it or hurt it in any way and
uh
but um
I'm looking forward to it I watched uh
not all of the episodes but some of them
looks like they're pretty well done
and um there's some issues I have with
some of the things and some of the
conversations that me and Michael have I
think we'll straighten it out
after this you know before it I don't
really care when but uh
so that's my opinion of it right now
got it so you know Michael Sammy maybe
uh it's good for the audience to hear
from your and when you first flew in and
we came to the property and we had that
one meeting together in the room it was
myself the two of you I want to say Kurt
was there I think Richie was a few
people were involved in that meeting
that we had in that room uh next door
what was your expectation going in and
then at the same time what was your uh
uh you know outcome at the end when
you're left was it what you expected it
to be when you left what was your
thoughts when you went in and when you
left Michael yourself
yeah I didn't know what to expect you
know Sammy and I have uh you know two
different uh perceptions of this life
both before and after
and I knew that that was going to be
some controversy between us and
obviously it was Patrick Ewa there you
know I think uh we got hated at times
because we do strongly disagree
um but you know all in all look we're
two made guys and at the end of the day
I think we knew how to conduct it
ourselves even though things got heated
at times you know it's kind of like a
blast back to the past and you kind of
remember the way things are supposed to
go and I think in the end they went that
way you know how we feel about each
other right now I don't know look Sammy
said something he said I didn't like and
maybe I said some things that he didn't
like and as a result there's still some
tension between us but that's just the
way it goes you know it's uh you know
how it how it ultimately ends up is
really you know depends on the two of us
and we'll see what happens
yeah well Michael it's not that you know
the way it ended I thought it ended good
I think it went well between us
and uh just recently you put out an into
uh a video
that I'm completely Disturbed with we
had language back and forth with each
other I think we know that's not
[ __ ]
so right now I feel betrayed by you
by what you put out
what we did on this
program
was a beautiful thing you're right it
was governor in full bloom again it made
me feel good about sitting with you it
maybe changed my opinion of you
and I think it went very well
we did have some heated times but end
result it went like goes in Austria it's
supposed to go
but what you did after that that video
really Disturbed the [ __ ] out of me up
until right now I didn't even want to
sit down on this video to tell you the
truth
but I'm in this deep I went in this far
and I'm not the type of guy who's going
to walk away and leave everybody
dangling
so
that's that's the way I feel from that
video but the the the
Mafia States of America that situation
and what Patrick did and what you did
yes we do have tremendous differences of
opinion
along as it goes in ocean
as far as destroying families and all of
that stuff you know it did to some
people but not to other people
and when we talk about people who
cooperated which you did as well
with Navi Waltons want to really get
into that right now but
you know to sit there and say you know
this is horrible what these people did
and they caught a break
and uh all of this stuff
and uh belittling them and putting them
down
for another program that's going to come
out with John Gotti Jr I I blew me away
and then the second thing you take you
prayed for me that's another thing that
bloom really blew me away because I'm
not a fool
I'm a street Thug I'm just as smart as
you maybe you underestimate my education
to compare to your education but I know
when I'm being [ __ ]
okey-doked or try to make me soft spot
uh get take it easy because of the video
it's not supposed to bother me no more
but it does and it made it that was that
guy sing on the cake to me
so it made me real Angry so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]